OPERATOR REDUCE WEIGHT.
MUSIC
CALLED FOR THE LINE COULD
SOMEBODY PLEASE CHECK ON THE
BUTTON.
SHE SHE.
YOU CAN READ
THE START WITH THIS. OKAY
MEMBERS WERE NEW- ESTABLISH A
QUORUM- QUICKLY- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GRAY
THERE BIGELOW AGUIAR-CURRY
BERMAN. BONTA BROKE. COOLEY
COOPER DALY. GALLAGHER. EDUARDO
GARCIA. GIPSON JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY LOW. MATHIS MELENDEZ
QUIRK SILVA. ROBERT RIVAS
BLANCA READ RUBIO. SALAS RIVER.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU-
SURGERY THANK YOU MEMBERS.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY GOVERNOR
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE TO START
LET ME APOLOGIZE FOR OUR
TARDINESS I PRESENTED A BILL IN
OUR OTHER COMMITTEE AND AS WE
ALL KNOW THERE ARE SOME
CHALLENGES TO THE SPEED- SAME
BILLS WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE CHALLENGES HERE
TODAY IN OUR COMMITTEE- DUE TO
THE CURRENT STAY HOME ORDER WE
OPPRESSION PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE. ADDED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCHING
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF SPACING
BETWEEN PEOPLE WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
MEMBERS STAFF AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC AND THE MEDIA HERE
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS. THERE
ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY AND HE- IS A MEMBER OF
THE BOOK- IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO FIND A BILL PLEASE.
SURE HANDED OUT TO MY AT THE- I
WOULD. THE PUBLIC CUTS THE- YOU
CAN HAVE THE HEARING YOU'RE
DONE TESTIFYING RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING LEAVING THE
CAPITOL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. FOR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING- IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. THOSE WITNESSES
WILL APPEAR IN THE SEARCH FOR
MEMBERS WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY
LIVE FROM OUTSIDE OF THE
HEARING ROOM AND ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THESE WITNESSES.
THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT DELAY FOR
THE STREAM FROM THE WEB VIDEO
ROOM SO PLEASE BE PATIENT. FOR
DIAL IN WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. IN THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWO. FOUR TWO SIX TWO. THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY GEO
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
IS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON HIS
BEGINNING AT THEIR BILL
PESENTATION. SO THAT YOU CAN
GET INTO THE QUEUE THE OPERATOR
LINE WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO BE PLACE IN THE QUEUE
BASED ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE BILL. IF YOU WERE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MOVING YOUR MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED IF YOU ARE THE MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST A BILL YOU WERE
REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE. IT WILL
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON O SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS OF
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE. TWO
FIVE THREE ONE OF MY STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO ASSIST. ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE-
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IN THE CHAMBER
MEMBERS IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND TO ROLL CALL ASK A
QUESTION PROVIDE A COMMON YOU
WILL NEED TO RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE SO STAFF CAN
ACTIVATE IT WHEN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. ALSO
PLEASE STAND UP AND FACE THE
MICROPHONE WILL SPEAKING TO
ENSURE YOUR VOICE IS AUDIBLE
AND CAN BE RECORDED. OKAY WITH
THAT. MEMBERS WE'VE ESTABLISHED
A QUORUM WE'VE READ THE
INSTRUCTIONS FOR THE PUBLIC AND
WE WILL MOVE TO THE AGENDA.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A THIRTEEN
BILLS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
TODAY. I HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND- SECRETARY- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL GRAY. I BIGELOW
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN. BONTA BRO
COOLEY. COOPER DALY. GALLAGHER
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON JONES
SAWYER LACKEY LOW. MATHIS
MELENDEZ QUIRK SILVA.
ROBERT RIVAS BLANCA RUBIO.
SALAS. BECAUSE THAT COUNTERS
BEEN ADOPTED. OKAY MEMBERS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAVING BEEN
ADOPTED WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
ITEM ONE ON OUR AGENDA AB
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS AT ALL BY MR SALAS
2% MR SAUCE WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE IS TO SHORE
CENTRAL WORKERS THAT WE RESPECT
THEM GIVE THEM THE PROPER
CLASSIFICATION. MOVED AWAY FROM
ADMINISTRATIVE AND CLERICAL FOR
ALL OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHERS. RESPECTFULLY
ASPIRIN I'VE OF. THANK YOU MR
SO. OR ONLINE OKAY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE PHONE WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE PHONE MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE IN GENERAL IF YOU WISH
TO SHOW SUPPORT OF A BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IN YOUR
FALL. COLLABORATOR GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER AND FURTHER
INSTRUCTIONS. IF USING A
SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE PICK UP
THE HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBER. AS A REMINDER TO SHELVE
THE PARTS OF AVAIL PLEASE PRESS
ONE. ZERO AT THIS TIME IN JUST
A MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THAT
WE GET THE PARTICIPANTS ARE
WHITE NUMBER.
AIRLINE OVER
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI WELCOME. I MEAN IT'S ONLY A
GRIPPING AND THAT THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN GENERAL
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT
OF ADDING DISPATCHERS AND MAYES
TELECOMMUNICATIONS LEYVA THE
DEFINITION OF WORKING UNDER.
HOWEVER MY THE BILL DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE SECTOR AND- ONE
PERFORM THE JOB AND BE EX ARE
OPPOSED BY THE MEASURE. OF A
FAITH. WE REPRESENT DISPATCHER
WELCOME THE PUBLIC SECTOR WHO
DESERVE AND WHAT IF PRE THAT
RECOGNITION. WILL START WITH
THE STATURE NOT PROUD OF THAT
AGAIN ON THE SAME. ON THE
PEOPLE PERFORM THIS BEST SOUNDS
AND THANKING ARE LOOKING SIDE
BY. WITH THE- SECTOR DISPATCH
AND ARE TO TEAM SECTOR RESPOND
UNITS. HAVE BEEN OUT OF THE
TRUCK. AND I AM AT BUT. GET THE
COMMUNICATION TODAY ALL OFFICE
AND HOPE THAT THAT CAN. RIGHT
NOW I WORK ONLINE SEVENTEEN
AGAIN LINE ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GET OUT GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CARE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU. MY NAME IS TINA BRAZIL I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE CHP PUBLIC
SAFETY DEFECTORS ASSOCIATION.
AND SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT. OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE WHY LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION. I AM
APPOINTED FASTER AT THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL AND
HAVE BEEN FOR TWENTY THREE
YEARS. PRIOR TO THAT I WORK AS
A LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT
DISPATCHER FOR SEVEN YEARS IN
PART OF THAT A WORK IS NANCY IN
THE DISPATCHER FOR ANY OF YOUR-
COMPANY. AB NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE. WELL RECOGNIZED PUBLIC
SAFETY DISPATCHER THEN TELL
COMMUNICATORS. FOR THE VERY
FIRST RESPOND OR IF WE TRULY
ARE IN THE EMERGENCY SYSTEM.
WHEN SOMEONE CALLED NINE ONE
ONE EMERGENCY HELP I AND ANY
OTHER DISPATCHER WHO PICKED UP
ONLINE IS THE FIRST RESPONDER.
WE DEAL WITH AN OVERWHELMING
AMOUNT OF STRESS DAY TO DAY.
VERY SELDOM DO WE GET THE FINAL
OUTCOME ON A CALL BECAUSE WE
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ONE AND THE
NEXT ONE AFTER THAT. AS
DISPATCHERS WE SAVE LIVES. WITH
ABSOLUTELY NO VISUAL WE
UNTANGLE A CLUSTER OF WORDS
BLURTED OUT WITH A BURST OF
ADRENALINE. FROM PANIC PEOPLE
AND LIFE THREATENING SITUATION.
WE PROVIDE LIFESAVING
INSTRUCTIONS AND GET LAW
ENFORCEMENT FIRE AND MEDICS TO
THE SCENE OF THE EMERGENCY.
MANY TIMES IT IS UP TO US TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE THAT EMERGENCY
IS BECAUSE THE CALLER CAN'T
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION. WE
KEEP THE PEOPLE ON THE PHONE WE
DEAL WITH THE SITUATION TO KEEP
THEM SAFE AND ALIVE. PUBLIC
SAFETY DISPATCHER WILL TELL
COMMUNICATORS ARE THE FIRST
RESPONSE. ARE THE FIRST TO
RESPOND TO. WAKE HIM PROGRESS.
THE MASSIVE VIOLENCE CALL. IF
SOMEONE TRAPPED INSIDE A
BURNING THE THINKING VEHICLE.
IF PEOPLE WANT THE AND
EVERYTHING BY TAKING THEIR OWN
LIFE. ROB RECENT PROGRESS. LIFE
THREATENING WILD FIRES WILL
STRUCTURE FIRE. THE CHILDREN
WHO ARE WITNESSING TERRIBLE
THING. TO ROAD RAGE. IT
CHILDREN BEING BORN WHILE EN
ROUTE TO THE HOSPITAL. WE
PROVIDE LIFE SAVING INFORMATION
AND INSTRUCTION AND DEFENSE THE
SECOND WAVE OF FIRST
RESPONDERS. OFFICERS MEDIC AND
FIREFIGHTERS. WE STAY ON THE
LINE WITH OUR CALLERS AS
NECESSARY. COMIC COLLECTED AND
CLEAR. ABOUT WHAT THAT COLUMN
MUST DO. PEOPLE CALL ME THE
THEY ARE AND- THIS BE THE WORST
DAY OF THEIR LIFE. AND THEY ARE
DEPENDING ON ME TO HELP THEM
AND I AM TRYING TO DO JUST THAT.
WE ARE THE LIFELINE FOR
OFFICERS AND FIREFIGHTERS OUT
IN THE FIELD. WE ARE A TEAM. WE
ARE IN CONSTANT CONTACT GIVE
THEM UPDATES ON THE SITUATION
BUT THEY ARE RESPONDING TO.
THANK YOU CALL ME WHEN THEY
HAVE AN EMERGENCY WAS SHOT
FIRED. ACCIDENT WHILE DOING. IT
TWICE THAT ARE BECOMING MORE
THREATENING THE OFFICERS AND
FIREFIGHTERS DEPEND ON US TO
MAKE SURE THEY GET THE HELP
THEY NEED. WE HAD A DISPATCHER
CAME RECOGNIZED THAT THE WOMAN
CALLING TO COMPLAIN THAT OUR
PEOPLE HAD BEEN DELIVERED YET.
ACTUALLY IN THE MIDDLE OF A
DANGEROUS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATION AND DIDN'T WANT THE
MAN THREATENED HER LIFE YOU
KNOW SHE WAS CALLING FOR HELP.
A DISPATCHER THAT TAKE THE CALL
FROM A SUICIDAL PERSON. THAT
BROKE INTO THE DELTA MENDOTA
CANAL AND THAT'S RECALL WITH
THINKING SHE CHANGED HER MIND.
THAT DEFECTOR TRIED WITH VERY
LITTLE TIME TO GET HER LOCATION
AND COULD NOT AS YOU HEARD THE
WOMAN SCREAMING AND CRYING. THE
OFF YOU SEE ON THE VEHICLE
TRACK IN THE VEHICLE THE NEXT
MORNING. FIRE DEFECTORS TAKING
CALLS OF PEOPLE SECOND BURNING
BUILDINGS AND TRYING TO GET
THEIR FIREFIGHTERS TO THEM.
THIS FACT YOU HAVE TAKEN RADIO
CALL FROM CITIZENS ONE OFF THE
LEAD FIREFIGHTERS HAVE BEEN
INJURED EVEN KILLED IN THE LINE
OF DUTY. THERE'S NO QUESTION IN
MY MIND THAT WE ARE. FIRST
RESPONDERS. IF YOU ARE
CURRENTLY CLASSIFIED CLERICAL
POSITION. AB NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE WOULD CHANGE THAT GIVEN
THAT THE PILOT FIRST RESPONDED
FOR THE CRITICAL ROLE WE HAVE A
HIGHLY TRAINED PUBLIC SAFETY
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE THE FIRST
TO ASSIST IN AN EMERGENCY. THE
TELEPHONE POINT YOUR PROFESSION
BECAUSE IT FINALLY GIVES US THE
TITLE IN STATE LAW THAT WE TOOK
AN OATH TO DO WHEN WE BECAME
DISPATCHERS. ALTHOUGH WE ARE
NOT THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND AT
THE SCENE OF THAT EMERGENCY. WE
ARE THE LIFE. THAT STARTS WITH
THE FROM THE GROUND. WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK ON
AB NINETEEN FORTY FIVE. WE HOPE
THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU HAVE A LINE OF.
THIS TIME I THINK WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO. THE VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOM TO HEAR FROM DON JONES
COMMUNICATIONS SUPERVISOR WITH
THE SONOMA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. I MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M DON JONES JUST BEST MANAGER
CINEMA COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE
EACH DAY AND I WENT DISPATCHERS
ANSWER THE CALL FOR HELP IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES WE TEACH
CHILDREN FROM A YEAH I HATE. IF
THERE'S A PROBLEM CALL NINE ONE
ONE AND HELP BE SENT WHILE
POLICE FIRE OR EMS ARE BEING
SENT AND I WANT DISPATCHES OUR
FIRST PROVIDE LIFE SAVING
MEDICAL INSTRUCTIONS SUCH AS
CPR OR WHAT TO DO IF SOMEONE IS
CHOKING. THEY PROVIDE DIRECTION
ON WHAT TO DO IF YOU'RE HIDING
IN YOUR HOME DURING A HOME
INVASION ROBBERY OR IF YOUR
CHILD IS MISSING. NOW IN
DISPATCHERS AND SURE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND FIREFIGHTERS
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE RESPONDING
TO THAT THEY TAKE THE PROPER
PRECAUTIONS FOR THEIR OWN
SAFETY AND THE SAFETY OF THOSE
NEARBY. MY ONE ONE DISPATCHERS
NEVER KNOW WHAT TYPE OF CALL
THEY ARE ANSWERING IT COULD BE
A SUICIDAL TEENAGER A BARKING
DOG A ROBBERY AT THE PARKING
COMPLAINT OR A CASE OF IDENTITY
THEFT AFTER THEY COMPLETE THAT
ALL THE MOST SO THE NEXT CALL
WITHOUT TIME TO DECOMPRESS
OFTEN GOING CALL TO CALL FOR
HOURS ON END. OVER THE YEARS
THIS IS A TOLL ON A NORMAL OUR
FAMILY AND LOVED ONES IT IS
VERY COMMON FOR FAMILY MEMBER
OR SPOUSE IS TRUE CAN WHO WERE
BUT THIS IN WHO WE ARE TODAY.
SOME OF THE CALLS HAVE TAKE
STILL HAUNT US WEEKS YEARS AND
EVEN DECADES LATER. I WILL
NEVER FORGET TAKING A CALL FROM
WOMAN WITH A SHOT IN THE HEAD
CHEST LET BY OUR OWN SON I
PROVIDED INSTRUCTIONS TO HELP
KEEP PRO LIVE IN THE FROM
NINETEEN PREVENTED HIM FROM.
KILLING HIS OWN GRANDMOTHER. IN
I AM ALL OF YOU WHAT WOULD YOU
DO TODAY YOU NEED. YOU WOULD
CALL NINE ONE ONE. I WANT
DISPATCHERS ARE A DUTY FOR YOU
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE DAYS A YEAR. IT TAKES A
SPECIAL PERSON TO DO THIS JOB.
WE ARE THE FIRST OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS FIRST ANSWER THE
CALL. FIRST TO PROVIDE HELP
THEM LIFESAVING INSTRUCTIONS
AND THE FIRST PROVIDE KEY HELP
AND GUIDANCE FOR BROTHER AND
SISTER FIRST RESPONDERS IN THE
FIELD. FOR THESE REASONS YOU
SHOULD SUPPORT A. B. NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ALL TODAY. THANK YOU DONNA
WILL. NOW MOVE BACK TO THE
PHONES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL-
SUPPORT. A LINE NUMBER FOURTEEN
AGAIN FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
ON A ROLL HERE IN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JAMIE
YOUNG AND I'M A RETIRED NINE
ONE ONE DIRECTOR FROM THE
COUNTY OF SAN MATTEO IN A
CURRENT CONSULTANT WITH MISSION
CRITICAL PARTNERS AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOUR COMMITTEE THIS
AFTERNOON IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE.
PROFESSIONAL I THINK THE NINE
ONE ONE TELE COMMUNICATOR.
CATION HUSBAND AND IS A PASSION
OF. MANY OF US WHO HAVE
DEDICATED OUR LIVES CAREER.TO
THE PROFESSION AND TO PUBLIC
SERVICE. THOUSANDS OF NINE ONE
ONE PROFESSIONALS ACROSS THE
NATION HAVE TAKEN ON THE
PURSUIT OF RECOGNIZING NINE ONE
ONE PROFESSIONALS ON MANY
FRONTS. INCLUDING THE FEDERAL
AND STATE LEGISLATION ON
RECLASSIFYING NINE ONE ONE
DISPATCHERS AS EMERGENCY
WORKERS ALIGNED WITH OUR FIELD
RESPOND HERS. CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE DEFINES THE PARAMETERS OF
THIS LEGISLATION WHICH SOME
BELIEVE IT IS A LONG OVERDUE
INITIATIVE CONSIDERING THE
MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL HEALTH
DISABILITIES WE ARE NOW FACING
IN THE NINE ONE ONE INDUSTRY.
TO THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
ASSEBLY MEMBER DOLLARS. I
THANK YOU FOR THIS RECOGNITION.
I'VE BEEN IN THE PROFESSION FOR
OVER FORTY YEARS THING A
DIRECTOR OF FIRE AMBULANCE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT NINE ONE ONE
CENTER. AND THERE'S NO TIME
LIKE THE PRESENT TO RECOGNIZE
THE PEOPLE BEHIND THE NINE ONE
ONE LICENSE. SO MANY LIVES ON A
REGULAR BASIS. WE DO NOT HAVE
TO SEE OR TOUCH THESE PEOPLE TO
BE AN OFFICIAL MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY PROTECTION. ALL
OF OUR EFFORTS MITIGATE CALLERS
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE DONE VIA
PHONE AND TAX. THE
TELECOMMUNICATION TAKES THE
WHOLE ONE DAY IN AND DAY OUT
NINE ONE ONE PROFESSIONALS HERE
PEOPLE AND SOME OF THE WORST
SITUATIONS THAT THEY'LL EVER BE
AN- BUT THE PROFESSIONALS ARE
RESILIENT AND THEIR RESOLVE TO
SERVE THE PUBLIC IS GREATER.
AND MORE COMPELLING OF A
CALLING. WELL I DO NOT
REPRESENT THE PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATION TODAY I AM A PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY NUMBER ASSOCIATION
TELL NINA. AND HAVE BEEN AND
STILL INVOLVED IN A NINE ONE
ONE INDUSTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION.
REPRESENTS STATE NATIONAL NINE
ONE ONE PROFESSIONALS IN
SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS AND- SOME
OF WHOSE SPONSOR AND OR
AFFILIATED WITH PUBLIC GROUP
SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA. POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION WHICH I
UNDERSTAND IT'S LEGISLATIVE.
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE RECENTLY
RECORD IT'S VERY WELCOME
SUPPORT OF NINETEEN FORTY FIVE.
TODAY IS AN IMPORTANT DAY IN
THE PROCESS OF THIS LEGISLATION
PASSED TO MAKE HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA WE CAN BE A LONG ONE
IT DOESN'T STATE WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE TRUE VALUE. NINE
ONE ONE TELE COMMUNICATORS
BRING TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ECOSYSTEM. AS A CANADIAN HERE'S
AND DOES NOT SEE MANY OF US TO
TESTIFY ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL I HOPE IT GIVES YOU
A GLIMPSE. OF WHAT THE NINE ONE
ONE DISPATCHER SPACE EVERY DAY
WHEN WE ARE ON THE PHONE.
HELPING PEOPLE AND SUPPORTING
THEM IN THEIR- IN THEIR NAME.
WE ARE ASKING YOU FOR HELP
RIGHT NOW GETTING. RECOGNITION
AND LONG OVERDUE. RECOGNITION
FOR THE EXCEPTIONAL SERVICE
THAT NINE ONE ONE DISPATCHERS
PROVIDE. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY- IN
SUPPORT. AND MODEL LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
THAT WE SHOWN MUCH LOWER HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION UP WITH RECORDS TO
PROVIDE THERE'S IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN AGAIN BLANKS
SEVENTY SEVEN. THE SECURE
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON
SHAMELESSLY IN ABOUT HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON OUR MILITARY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CHEAP ELIZABETH MATHEUS
WITH THE BIRTHING POLICE
DEPARTMENT I AM THE TI PLAYS ON
FROM THE SANTA COUNTY POLICE
CHIEFS AND SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
TO THE FAMILY TELL COUNTY
COMMUNICATION MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TO YOU ON
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE. I AM HERE TO EXPRESS MY
PERSONAL SUPPORT AS WELL AS ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN MATEO COUNTY
POLICE CHIEFS AND SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION FOR AB NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE WHICH WOULD REDEFINE
PUBLIC SAFETY DISPATCHER AND
PUBLIC SAFETY TEL COMMUNICATOR
AS A FIRST RESPONDER. AT THE
PRIOR PUBLIC SAFETY DISPATCHER
MYSELF OVER THIRTY YEARS AGO
BEFORE BECOMING A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER I
UNDERSTAND THE HIGHLY SKILLED
IN HER OVER QUIRK THESE
INDIVIDUALS DO EVERY DAY AND
THEY ARE THE FIRST ONES TO
ANSWER THE CALL DURING AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION AND ARE THE
FIRST TO HAVE CONTACT WITH THE
VICTIM CALLING IN FEAR IN GREAT
DISTRESS. THEY ARE FIRST
RESPONDERS PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHERS PLAY SUCH A VITAL
ROLE IN EMERGENCY RESPONSE THAT
EXTENDS FAR BEYOND THE FACT YOU
FOR SERVICE THERE A LOT BY PER
MEDI EIGHT SO SHE AND HOPPED
OUT TO A LOT SAVE DIRECT IN
ACTIVE SHOOTER THE- PROVIDING
DIRECTION DURING NATURAL. AND
BUYERS AND SO MUCH MORE THERE
THE LINE OFF. IT'S FUNNY TO
IMPROPER IN YEAH BUT IN.
INDEPENDENT ON THAT MEDIA AN
UPDATE OF. DOES THAT IS ALSO
VERY SOME OF THE STRESS
INDICATORS OTHER MY RISK. IF
THE AS PETE. SECONDARY TRY
EXPOSED AND- CITY. I BELIEVE IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY DISPATCHERS BE
RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR VITAL
CONTRIBUTION TO THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY THEY PROVIDE TO OUR
COMMUNITY. COMMUNITIES BY
CLASSIFYING THEM AS FIRST
RESPONDERS. I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB NINETEEN FORTY FIVE
AND STAND WITH US IN MAKING A
CLEAR STATEMENT THAT RECOGNIZES
DISPATCHERS FOR THE LIFESAVING
WORK. THAT THEY PERFORM AT
FIRST RESPONDERS EVERY DAY THEY
COME TO WORK. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ALLOWED ME TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF AB NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE. ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. DO I HAVE
LINE NUMBER FORTY NINE AGAIN
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE TWENTY NINE PLEASE CHECK A
MUTE BUTTON. EIGHT HEARING NONE
ANY- SUPPORT OPPOSITION. OKAY
HEARING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND-MISTER SAUCE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE- OUT HOLD ON WE
HAVE TESTIMONY SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION AND STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION SUPPORT MARK SMITH
ON BEHALF OF HE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY NUMBER ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. OKAY ANY
OTHER TESTIMONY SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION HEARING NONE MR
SALAS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE-
AND LET ME JUST SAY I'LL TAKE-
ALL OF THE POINTS THAT WERE
MADE FROM THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE THAT CALLED IN SUPPORT.
AS MY CLOTHES- WE HAVE NEARLY
FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS I BELIEVE
DOWN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
OKAY MOST A SECOND SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS GRAY. HI BIGELOW.
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN. BERMAN I
BONTA BONTA I BROKE. BRO I
COOLEY. COOLEY AYE COOPER DALY
DLY I GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I
EDUARDO GARCIA AND WATER GARCIA
AYE GIPSON. JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I'D LACKEY. LOW LOW I
MATHIS. MATHIS HI MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK
SILVA AYE ROBERT RIVAS. BLANCA
RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS HI THE BILL IS OUT. OKAY
THAT BILLS OUT MEMBERS- WE ARE
NOW NOW WE'RE A LITTLE OFF FOR
NORMAL GEO PACE BUT I KNOW MR
LEVINE IS ABOUT TO HELP US
REGAIN ON LAP TWO SO MR LEVINE
IF YOU WERE TO PRESENT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE MEMBERS TO ITEM NINE
ON YOUR AGENDA AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT. LEVINE. WE HAVE
A MOTION A SECOND REGIONALLY
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN WAS VERY GOOD TO SEE
ALL OF YOU THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH CONDITIONS THAT WOULD
ALLOW PS PS IS PUBLIC POWER
PUBLIC SAFETY OUR SHOPS TO BE-
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED- A STATE OF
EMERGENCY. YOUR LOCAL
EMERGENCY. YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SIR- ANY TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. THIS IS JOHN KENNEDY
WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTED THE CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT THIRTY SEVEN OF
CALIFORNIA RURAL COUNTIES OUR
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN- HIT
PARTICULARLY HARD BY WILDFIRES
IN RECENT YEARS AND WE
EXPERIENCE MOST OF BLASTERS PS
YES THE VENT SO ALL I'LL TRY TO
BE BRIEF YEP YEP DEMAND WE
UNDERSTAND THE NECESSITY FOR
HAVING- NARROWLY TAILORED YEAH
YES THE VENT BUT THEY'VE TAKEN
A TREMENDOUS TOLL ON CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES. MANY COMMUNITIES
EXPERIENCE SIX PM GET THE BAND
LAST YEAR SOME OF WHICH WERE
BACK TO BACK FOR POWERS FULLY
RESTORED TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT POWER AND
WE HAD MASSIVE LOSSES OF
COMMUNICATION CAPABILITIES BOTH
AMONG RESIDENTS AND AMONG FIRST
RESPONDERS SO NEW THAT IT JUST
MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR. US
TO PERFORM OUR PERSONAL SERVICE
AND FOR RESIDENTS TO CONTACT
EMERGED ON SO WE SUPPORT AB ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THE CHOIR AT THE DE
ENERGIZED SEVEN SUPPORT YES THE
ACCIDENTS QUALIFY. THEM. FOR
WHICH A STATE AGENCY OR
EMERGING CAN BE TO CLEAR YOU
KNOW WE HAVE SEVERAL OF
GOVERNMENTS ADOPTED. SOME HERE
YEAH TO DECLARATION LAST YEAR
THANK SEVERAL BY MEMBERS. THE
CLERK WILL PROVIDE THE
ADDITIONAL TO FOR LOCAL TOURIST
IF YOU GET THE- AND TO SEEK
FINANCIAL. WORK HERE YES RELY
COSTS. SO WITH THAT WE WERE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS THE-
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. HEARING
NONE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. HEARING NONE LET ME
BRING IT BACK TO QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERS. SEEING NONE OR
BACK TO MR LEVINE FOR YOUR
CLOTHES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I.
EVER MEMBERS WE HAVE A MOTION
SECOND SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GRAY AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW I AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN
BERMAN I BONTA BONTA AYE BRO.
BRO I COOLEY. COOLEY AYE COOPER
DALY DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GIPSON.
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. LOW LOW AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE
QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA AYE
ROBERT RIVAS. BLANCA RUBIO
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS HI
THE BILL IS OUT. OKAY THAT
BILLS OUT AND AT THIS TIME
LOOKING TO THE REAR THE
CHAMBERS I DON'T SEE IN
ADDITION ANY ADDITIONAL. AUTHOR
SO I THINK I'M ON THE ASK IF
ANY OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PERHAPS- MISTER BIGELOW IS
PREPARED TO PRESENT. ITEM
TWELVE. TWO MEMBERS REMOVED I
AM TWELVE IN YOUR GENDER AB.
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE BY
MISTER BIGELOW. WE HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND WAS BIGELOW
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR ON JUST A FEW COMMENTS
LET ME FIRST RECOGNIZE THAT'LL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES-
AMENDMENTS OF TAKING BE TAKING
THAT AND- JUSTIN IN TRYING TO
MAKE THINGS SHORT FOR EVERYONE
HERE ON THE COMMENTS. WHERE
POSES A VERY SMALL COMMUNITY
IT'S A SMALL COUNTY ABOUT
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH
THIS ACTION SOME MIGHT WANT TO
QUESTION IT BUT THE REALITY IS
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT MARIPOSA
AND WHAT IT REALLY TREATS MOST
OF ITS MONEY. IS DERIVED FROM
TERRORISM THE TOURISM COMES
MOSTLY FROM USE EMITTING YOU
SOMEBODY HAS NEARLY FIVE
MILLION ATTENDEES EACH YEAR.
THIS SHOWCASES. WHAT THE NEED
AND THE MAGNITUDE OF NEEDY IS
FOR THE COMMUNITY. TO FULFILL
THOSE VISITORS WHO ARE GONNA
WANNA COMMON ENJOYED THE LOCAL
RESTAURANTS AND VENUES THERE IN
THE COMMUNITY SO I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS AN
ASSET THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT
THIS PARTICULAR BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I
BELIEVE I HAVE SOMEBODY THAT'S-
GOING TO BE A WITNESS HERE IF
HE CAME ONLINE. THANK YOU
MISTER BIGELOW AND I BELIEVE WE
HAVE SUPERVISOR- KEVIN CAME
FROM- MARIPOSA COUNTY WITH US
ON THE PHONE PERHAPS. IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I AM KEVIN
CAN SHARE THE MIRACLES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. AS A- AS
OUR REPRESENTATIVE ASSEMBLYMAN
BIGELOW SAID WE HAVE ABOUT
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
RESIDENTS IN MARIPOSA COUNTY
BUT WE HOST. FORTY FIVE MILLION
VISITORS A YEAR TO YOSEMITE
VALLEY WHICH IS PART OF OUR
COUNTY. THAT'S AN INCREASE OF
TWO AND A HALF MILLION SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY. 80% OF THESE
VISITORS OVERNIGHT OUTSIDE OF
THE PARK MOSTLY IN GATEWAY
COMMUNITIES. MOST QUALITY
LODGING FACILITIES REQUIRE A
FULL SERVICE RESTAURANT WITH ON
SITE LIQUOR SERVICE. COUNTY
RESIDENTS IN SUPERVISORS ARE
FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS LIQUOR
LICENSE INCREASE WHICH IS
TARGETED FOR FOOD SERVICE
FACILITIES WITH A MINIMUM
SEATING CAPACITY OF AT LEAST
FIFTY. COUNTY BUSINESSES
LITERALLY SERVE MILLIONS OF
TOURISTS ANNUALLY WITH
OVERNIGHT ACCOMMODATIONS AND
FOOD SERVICE WE WORK EXTREMELY
CLOSELY WITH OUR NEIGHBORS
NEIGHBORING COUNTIES ON THESE
ISSUES AS FULLY ONE AND A HALF
MILLION OF THOSE VISITORS COME.
ON ROUTE ONE FORTY THROUGH THE
TOWN AMER SAID INTO THE TOWN
AMERICA'S ANY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARC. AIRPORTS COUNTY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SUPERVISOR
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. THIS IS JOHN KENNEDY
AGAIN WITH RC RC- AGAIN
REPRESENTING THIRTY SEVEN WORLD%
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES TOURISM IS
AN ECONOMIC ENGINE AND MANY OF
OUR COUNTIES DROUGHT MILLIONS
OF VISITORS TO THE STATE FROM
AROUND THE WORLD WE'RE VERY
HAPPY TO CO SPONSOR THIS BILL
WITH MARIPOSA COUNTY TODAY. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. HEARING
NONE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. HEARING NONE LET'S-
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS
FOR QUESTIONS. SEE SEEING NONE
LET'S MOVE IT BACK TO MISTER
BIGELOW FOR. A CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS. BILL BIGELOW WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED WITH
THE MEN'S TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. GRAY HI GREAT I
BIGELOW BIGELOW I AGUIAR-CURRY
BERMAN BERMAN I BONTA. BONTA
AYE BRO WROTE I COOLEY COOLEY
AYE COOPER DALY. DALY AYE
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER I EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I GIPSON
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LOW LOW AYE
MATHIS MATHIS I MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE ROBERT RIVAS.
BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO AYE
SALAS. SALAS I'D BILLS OUT WITH
SEVENTEEN VOTES OKAY MEMBERS
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
MISTER BIGELOW AT THIS TIME
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO LOOK TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALAR DEVIL I
SEE IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBERS
WOULD YOU PLEASE APPROACH AND
PRESENT. YOUR BILL WHICH IS
ITEM NUMBER FIVE ON OUR AGENDA
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR. YOU HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
TO YOU AND MEMBERS I AM
PRESENTING. AB TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR WHICH WILL ESTABLISH THAT
COMMUNITY RESPONSE INITIATIVE
TO STRENGTHEN EMERGENCY SYSTEMS
THE CRISIS ACT PILOT PROGRAM
THAT WILL PROMOTE COMMUNITY
BASED RESPONSES TO LOCAL
EMERGENCY SITUATION. EVERY DAY
IN COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE SUCCESSFULLY RESPONDING TO
TYPE TYPES OF EMERGENCY
SITUATION. BETTER PEOPLE
DEALING WITH HOMELESSNESS
EXPERIENCING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS EXPOSED TO INTIMATE
PARTER PARTNER COMMUNITY
VIOLENCE EXPERIENCING SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AN IMPACTED BY NATURAL
ARE CLIMATE DISASTERS IN FACT
WE HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THIS JUST EARLIER WITH THE BILL
THAT WAS PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS. IN LA ORGANIZED
LIKE SECOND CALL AND MUTARD
SEED INTERVENE TO BUILD PEACE
DURING NEIGHBORHOOD CONFLICTS.
IN THE BAY AREA THE BERKELEY
FREE CLINIC PROVIDES HEALTHCARE
SERVICES THE PEOPLE WHO ARE AND
SHELTERED OR ARE STRUGGLING
WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER.
AND STOCKTON FAMILY. AND
FATHERS OF SAN JOAQUIN WORK
CLOSELY. WITH THE CITY. TO
ENSURE THE CITY'S MOST
VULNERABLE ON HOUSE RESIDENTS
ARE SHELTERED. CALVET NINETEEN
HAS CREATED A CLUSTER OF ALL
SORTS OF THINGS AND HAS
STRESSED OUT NOT ONLY
COMMUNITIES BUT OUR SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS. PHOEBE HOURS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE ARE STEPPING
UP. AS THEY ALWAYS HAVE
DELIVERING FOOD SETTING UP HAND
WASHING STATIONS SCHERING
LIFESAVING INFORMATION AND
SUPPORTING SURVIVORS WHO ARE
SHELTERING IN PLACE AN UNSAFE
HOMES. WE ARE SEEING WITH KOBE
NINETEEN THAT OUR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ARE BEST
POSITIONED TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. WHEN
THEY'RE RESOURCE TO DO THIS
CRITICAL WORK ALL OF US.
BENEFIT AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
WELL ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO
SUPPORT AND SCALE OF THESE
EFFORTS. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT IN
A CITY OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND
EACH NEW NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION LEADS TO A ONE
POINT 2% DROP IN THE HOMICIDE
RATE. 1% REDUCTION IN VIOLENT
CRIME AND ALMOST A 1% REDUCTION
IN THE PROPERTY CRIME RATE.
ACCORDING TO THE FBI. UNIFORM
CRIME REPORT. NATIONWIDE
VIOLENT OFFENSES COUNT FOR JUST
A FRACTION OF THE ELEVEN TO
FOURTEEN MILLION ARRESTS. MADE
EACH YEAR MOST ARE PROPERTY
CRIMES THAT DO YOU WHY. AND
DRUG OFFENSES. THESE NON
VIOLENT OFFENSES ARE EXPENSIVE
THE PROCESS TAKE LONGER
GOVERNMENTS. AND ADD WE ARE
EXPERIENCING TO RECALL THE
NINETEEN WE NEED TO IMPROVE OUR
PUBLIC RESPONSES. TO THESE ANTI
SOCIAL BEHAVIORS. IN A WAY THAT
DOESN'T OVERBURDEN. ARE ALREADY
OVER WHEN I'M STRUCTURE. WE'VE
MEMBERS OUR CURRENT HOUSE
PRICES HAVE REVEALED WEAKNESSES
IN THE HOLES IN THE SYSTEM. AND
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO ALL
MEN AND IMPROVE OUR GENERAL
PUBLIC SAFETY. ACTUALLY IN
LIGHT OF OUR CURRENT FISCAL
DEFICIT WHICH WILL FORCE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND DEPARTMENTS TO
INDOOR MASSIVE CUTS. IN FOR LOS.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE
MONEY YOU KNOW I LOVE TALKING
ABOUT THE MONEY. THE TWENTY
FOURTEEN WORKERS COMPENSATION
COSTS FOR SWORN EMPLOYEES WERE
A HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. NATION WIDE AN
ESTIMATED NINE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS WAS
SPENT ON LAW ENFORCEMENT I'M
JUST TRANSPORTING PEOPLE WITH
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
THE LA FIRE OFFICIALS TOLD THE
LA TIMES THEY WERE SPENDING
NEARLY NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR. I'M OVER TIME TO COVER
SHIPS LEFT VACANT BY INJURED
FIREFIGHTERS. AND ACCORDING TO
THE LA CITY CONTROLLER IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN ONE IN THREE
LAPD OFFICERS FILED A WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIM. CLASSES
NEARLY A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR LIVING 15% OF
THE DEPARTMENTS HUMAN RESOURCES
ON THE SIDELINE. YOU WON'T KNOW
THIS THESE ARE EXTREMELY
STRESSFUL JOBS SITUATION AND AS
A RESULT OF POVERTY. NATURAL
DISASTERS ARE GROWING MENTAL
HEALTH. AN OPIOID EPIDEMIC. AND
I HAVE RESPONDING TO OUR
CURRENT PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
THE FIRST RESPONDERS ARE DOING
MORE THAN EVER AND PROBABLY
MORE THAN THEY BARGAINED FOR.
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR IS NOT
ABOUT REPLACING THIS IMPORTANT
AN EXISTING WORKFORCE. IT IS A
PLAN TO UTILIZE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROTECT FIRST
RESPONDERS. WHILE MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY. WITH ME
AND SUPPORT IS JACQUI MARROQUIN
WITH CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO
END DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND MRS
SANTA BARBARA WAKING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH BURKE. OKAY WE
HAVE. GO AHEAD. AND TELL
NINETEEN HUNDRED THE ONLY
ELECTRIC LINE THAT WITHIN YOU
THAT WITH A SINGLE WIRE AT
LEAST ACCOUNT OF TELEGRAPH WITH
BRING THAT THE PROSPECT OF
ELECTRICITY IN A HOME OR
BUSINESS I AM NOT FRIGHTENING
FIVE AND THERE WAS MUCH DEEPER.
WHEN THEY GET THAT NEWSPAPER
BEGAN TO WRITE A WEEKLY COLUMN
CALLED ELECTRICAL FLASH. HOW
DID THE MANY WAYS THAT
ELECTRICITY CAN MAKE LIFE
EASIER FOR EVERYONE. FOR
INSTANCE A SHOPPER WOULD NO
LONGER NEED TO SHATTER HIS
WINDOW THAT NIGHT AT THE SIMPLE
LIFE UP TO PROTECT KIDS
STOREFRONT FROM VANDALS OR A
HOME COULD BE HEATED BY
ELECTRICAL WIRES. AND ALLOWS
POLITICAL STOVE AND A MOTORIZED
FAN TO KEEP THE HOUSE COOL
DURING THE SUMMER HELLO ALL OF
WHICH WERE VERY. OKAY I THINK
WE HAVE. VISIT MIRACLE MUSICAL
TO OUR TESTIMONY HERE. THANK
YOU IS COMMENT EVER BRING IN A
LITTLE. MINE WITH A UNIQUE FORM
OF PROP THAT WOULD CAN ONLY IF
LOOKINGAMERICAN THE COUNTY THE
FLOW OF A RIGHT MODERATOR IF
YOU WANNA GO AHEAD AND CUT THE-
PHONE LINE. WE WILL RETURN TO
ANY IN PERSON- TESTIMONY AT THE
MOMENT DO I SEE ANY IN PERSON
WE HAVE A VIDEO- WITNESS
TESTIMONY. HELLO WITNESS
TESTIMONY AND WE HAVE NO IN
PERSON WITNESSES TESTIMONY. ARE
TWO WITNESSES WERE TELEPHONIC.
I SEE WE'RE EXPERIENCING
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA GO WITH THE FLOW.
OKAY DO WE HAVE SOMEONE JOINING
US IN SUPPORT ON THE TELEPHONE
LINE. HERNANDEZ JACQUI
MEDICALLY NOT. OKAY THANK YOU
DO HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. HEARING
NONE WILL GO AHEAD MOVED TO ANY
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION. HELLO
I. GO AHEAD TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT NAME ORGANIZATION. MY
NAME IS THE PARKING LOT WHERE
CAN I AM WITH MH BURKE I'M ALSO
AN EMERGENCY LAWMAKERS SHOULD
NOT SACRAMENTO I'VE SPENT OVER
A DECADE WORKING IN SOME OF THE
STATE'S MOST NOTABLE INPATIENT
PSYCHIATRIC HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES AND NOW NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS ONLY A DOLLAR
PEDIATRIC LEVEL ONE TRAUMA
CENTER IT IS NOT THAT ARE
CURRENTLY FOR HEALTH WITH THEN
ISRAELI SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMPLETELY. REMEMBER.
HEAVILY ON THIRTY FOUR A FIFTY
IN THE GAPS. IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH GREAT DOCTORS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WE CREATE A
LIKE TO HELP FIRST INMATES FOR.
ALBUM THAT PART BOND WITH THEM
BACK. OUR MODEL LONG PATIENTS
FULLER CARD INTO THE- AND LET
CARD. SACRAMENTO AN AVERAGE OF
FIVE LOOK FOR HELP BECAUSE THE
NINE ONE ONE DALY A BILL COST
PERCENT OR MORE ONE IN THE A
CAR FOR. THE NUMBERS WILL NOT A
X. THAT YOU'VE GOT RESULT IN.
ASSUMING EACH IS THE IF I COULD
RATED THROUGH THE WITH OF A
FIFTY FIFTY ARE THREE. WITHIN
OUR OF TWO HUNDRED AND ONE
DOLLAR DAILY CALL THE CURRENT
PLAN WILL COST THAT IN OKAY
ALONE OVER FIVE MILLION. YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY BE A RESOURCE
THE COURT IF A PROGRAM LIKE IN
NATURE. CAPACITY THE CAPS.
CAPITAL IT WILL KEEP NEIGHBOR.
OUT OF JAIL. IN THEIR HOME.
MUCH NEEDED HOSPITAL AND YOU
WELL WILL PURSUE FOR DISTANCE
DO THEIR JOBS. AND SIX COUNTY
MILLION OF DOLLARS. ESPECIALLY
RIGHT NOW MITIGATE THE- FINANCE
IMPACT OF ONE OF BY WITH.
MUSICALLY ADDRESSING. GONE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS WILL COST
MORE THAN WE CAN AFFORD BOTH
MENTALLY MORALLY AND PHYSICALLY.
MH FIRST AT THE BAR COLLECTION
OF STORIES ABOUT THE PEOPLE
THAT NEED HELP TO GET THROUGH
THE NIGHT AND AS MUCH AS I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THEM WITH
YOU IT WILL BE A VIOLATION OF
THEIR PRIVATE. BUT I CAN'T SAY.
THAT YEAH HELP YOUNG VULNERABLE
PEOPLE KEEP THEIR HOW BIG.
REPORTED SEVERAL COMMUNITY
MEMBERS STRUGGLING TO FIND
REASONS TO LIVE. GIVEN OVER ONE
CARE GIVER. THAT THEY NEED TO
TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES. THE
PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE HOPE COME
FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE MALE
FEMALE TRANS NON BINARY. THEY
COME FROM AN ARRAY OF SOCIAL
ECONOMIC LEVEL THE COLD SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND THAT. YOU HAVE
DONE THAT WOULD VOLUNTEER
DOCTORS VOLUNTEER NURSES
INVOLVED COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
DOWN A BILL CALLED THE FIVE IN
FACE WITH YOUR HELP WE CAN HAVE
A NEED TWENTY FIFTY FOUR AND
EIGHTEEN COULD BUILDING
EXPANDED. BASED APPLE STRUCTURE.
SUPPORT OUR PEOPLE IN QUITE THE-
AS SEE NOTHING BECAUSE BY WHAT
A DURING THE AND THEN I LOVE
BUT START WITH EVEN THE NEED.
FOR OUR PEOPLE INTRODUCING A
THEM AN AWFUL AND ARE. WE ARE
LOCAL LOW SOMEONE ARE WE ARE
THAT SOMEONE WITH LOCAL ILLNESS
AND TARGET I YOU WILL FOR
FURNITURE ONE ARE YOURSELF HE
LIFTED UP WITH THE CURRENT HAND
AND. NOT HANDCOCK. THANK YOU.
JACK. I AM THE DIRECTOR PROGRAM
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. PARTNERSHIP
IS A STATE WIDE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE COALITION WE REPRESENT
TWO HUNDRED ORGANIZATION
SERVING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I'VE BEEN IN THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FEEL NOW FOR
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS. OF WORKING
IN A LOCAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROGRAM IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FOR THE FIRST TEN YEARS OF MY
CAREER. IN THAT CAPACITY I WORK
DIRECTLY WITH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE SURVIVORS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. I WAS THE
PERSON WHO PICKED UP FAMILIES
AT THE POLICE DEPARTMENT AT ALL
HOURS OF THE NIGHT AND
TRANSPORTED THEM TO A
CONFIDENTIAL EMERGENCY SHELTER.
I WENT TO COURT WITH SURVIVORS
WITHOUT THINKING RESTRAINING
ORDERS HAVE TO BE ORDERED AND
WORST PROCEEDING. OFTEN
STARTING UP ACCORDING TO
SPANISH SPEAKING PROVIDERS.
OKAY CONTRADICTION MY TO DO. OF
THE WORK. WHAT THE FACT THAT I
KNEW THAT MY OWN MIX STATUS
IMMIGRANT SPANISH SPEAKING
FAMILIES WOULD NEVER AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF BENEFITS I
PROVIDED. JUST THE THOUGHT OF
GETTING ONE. OR COURT INVOLVED
FOR SURVIVORS IN MY FAMILY.
INTO THE SHADOWS. INSTEAD WHAT
THEY WANTED WITH PRETTY GOOD.
WHICH IS THE VERY THING I ALSO
HEARD FROM MANY. I HEARD THINGS
LIKE I DON'T WANT TO SEPARATE
OUR FAMILY I DON'T WANT ANYONE
YEAH I DON'T WANT TO KEEP MY
CHILDREN FROM THE OTHER PARENT.
I DO HOWEVER WANT THE OTHER
PARENT COFFEE THANK. I WANT.
ONE WE NOW TRADITIONAL SERVICES
DO YOU THINK LIVE AND PROVIDE
HOWEVER WE OFTEN LACK FOR
EVERYONE SURVIVOR WHO DOES
REACH OUT THERE ARE MANY MORE
LIKE THE TWO GENERATIONS OF MY
FAMILY OR DESPERATE FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ON THE STOCK
VIOLENCE BEFORE IT BEGINS OR
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN. A TWENTY FIFTY FOUR WHAT
OFFER ANOTHER OPTION ANOTHER
WAY TO ADDRESS ISSUES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH OUR- OPTION
THAT WILL TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
VERY THING THAT MANY FAMILIES
IN THE SHADOWS. A SEPARATE
FAMILY HERE AT THE LOCATION OF
THE CORPORATION. AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THE GLOBAL PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS SURVIVORS FAMILY
THE COMMUNITIES ARE
EXPERIENCING INCREASED TRACTION
FACTORS THAT TRIGGER MORE ON.
HOW TO CRISIS LINE REQUEST FOR
EMERGENCY SHELTER CALL CLOSE
WORKING HAVE INCREASED AND
THAT. UNMET NEED A CLEAR AS IS
THE NEED FOR COMMUNITY. BASED
ON SOME. GATHER WITH THE KIND
OF LIKE CRACKED INTERVENTION
SERVICE AND WITHOUT. WE CAN
HELP INTERVIEW AND THE CYCLE OF
VIOLENCE ONE AND FOR ALL. AB
FROM OR EIGHTY FIFTY FOUR
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR ABOUT.
OKAY I THINK WE HAVE. SIR MORE.
ME TOO TESTIMONIALS ON THE
PHONE SO IF WE COULD GET NAME
ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. WIND OF NINETY SIX
CAN LINE NUMBER NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOUR CALIFORNIA
PROUD COSPONSORED THE BILL
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL ITEM
A ONE A PORT. LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO OKAY DOES VERY MY NAME IS
KEVIN BOLTS- I'M A COMMUNITY
ACTIVIST IN SACRAMENTO I WANT
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TO THE NTH
DEGREE AND POINT OUT. THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO GO VERY FAR IN A
CASE LIKE JOSEPH MAN IN
SACRAMENTO WHO WAS EXECUTED BY
FACT PT THE CITY WHERE FUNDING
FOR ORGANIZATIONS COULD HAVE
PROMOTED PREVENT AND- PROMOTED
LIFE AND FERMENTED IS THAT. IN
THAT SITUATION SO I HUMBLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE YES THANK
YOU. NOW LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS CARLY BRANDON I AM THE
ADMINISTRATOR FOR AND A
VOLUNTEER FOR MENTAL HEALTH
FIRST IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA-
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BECAUSE
IT REALLY HELPS WITH SELF
DETERMINED CITY PLANNING. AND
OTHER SUPPORT THAT- FOLKS MAY
NOT BE GETTING OTHERWISE. RIGHT
IN LINE NUMBER EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JENNIFER REAL HOT I AM
A POLICY ADVOCATE WITH AC L. U.
OF GOING CALIFORNIA OUT THE
ACLU SO CAL IS A CO SPONSORING
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR. AND WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO PASS
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR TODAY THANK
YOU. REPLY NUMBER FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN LINE NUMBER FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALRIGHT
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
FOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS JOHN. I ACTUALLY- CONTEMPT
CHARGES COMMITTEE IS HOME IN HE
HAS JUST RECENTLY NOTED HOW TO
CONVERT NINETEEN CRISIS WILL BE
GENERATED MORE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISES AND WE NEED MORE
RESOURCES IN THAT OUR COMMUNITY
BASED IN ORDER TO RESPOND TO
THESE CRISIS IN MOST PRODUCTIVE
MANNER POSSIBLE PLEASE VOTE YES
FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU. AND NO
MORE FOR THE FALL AND. ANY
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
HEARING NONE A TEST WERE IN
OPPOSITION. HEARING NONE WILL
BRING YOU BACK TO THE MEMBERS
FOR QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE WILL
TAKE IT BACK TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COM LARGER DEBT FOR HER
CLOTHES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE. OKAY MEMBERS WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
GRAY AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BERMAN BERMAN AYE BONTA BONTA I
BROKE WROTE I COOLEY. COOLEY
AYE COOPER DALY DALY AYE
GALLAGHER EDUARDO GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GIPSON
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LOW LOW AYE
MATHIS MATHIS I MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE ROBERT RIVAS.
BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO AYE
SALAS. SALAS AYE THE BILL'S OUT
WITH SEVENTEEN VOTES. OKAY.
MEMBERS THAT BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER. AT THIS
TIME MEMBERS- WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK TO OUR COLLEAGUE MR ALONE
WHO'S IN THE REAR THE CHAMBERS
TO PRESENT ITEM TEN AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTEEN RELATED TO OFFICE
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND MODEL
GUIDELINES. MISS LEMOND PLEASE
PROCEED THANK. YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND GREAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH KAREN MEMBERS AND I
WANT TO START MAKE THAT THE
COMMITTEE AND AMENDMENTS AND
THAT ARE INCLUDED AND TO ALSO
THINK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE SEVEN MONTHS
AGO WE STARTED THE
CONVERSATION- ABOUT AT THIS
TOPIC ABOUT A NONPROFIT AND
VOLUNTEERS AND WHAT A MODEL AT
WHAT A MODEL PROGRAMMING
GUIDELINES COULD LOOK LIKE AND
SO WE'RE HOPING TO CONTINUE
THAT CONVERSATION. AND IN LIGHT
OF EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENING
CERTAINLY MORE RELEVANCE NOW
THAN IT WAS SEVEN MONTHS AGO
BUT SEVEN MONTHS AGO YOU KNEW
THAT AFTER THE FIRE I HELPING
NONPROFITS AND VOLUNTEERS
UNDERSTAND THEIR ROLE DURING
EMERGENCY SERVICES WAS CRITICAL
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE I DO HAVE A TO INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE ON THE PHONE AND WHO I
THINK PREPARED TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I LUCY
SELFIE DOPE. AT WITH A AT CAL
NONPROFITS AT POLICY DIRECTOR
AND CURTIS CHILD LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH. OKAY PLEASE
PLEASE BE ON I'M HAPPY TO. GO
FIRST. I'M LOSING SELF YOU KNOW
CARTER POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS OFTEN ON THE CAL
NONPROFIT. WE ARE A POLICY A
LINE OF MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE BOYS FOR
CALIFORNIANS NONPROFIT- AS YOU
KNOW YOUR OWN DISTRICT WE'RE
SEEING DURING THIS CURRENT
CRISIS WHAT WE SEE IN ANY
CRISIS. CALIFORNIA'S NON
PROFITS ARE STEPPING UP TO
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND
VITAL PROGRAMS TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND TO VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IN PARTICULAR.
COMMUNITY HEALTH CLINICS ARE
FIGURING OUT HOW TO GET PP SO
THEY CAN OFFER LOCAL IN PERSON
HEALTH CARE THEY'RE ALL
BUILDING UP THEIR TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURES. SO THAT THEY
CAN TAKE SERVICES ONLINE WHERE
POSSIBLE HOUSING PROGRAMS ARE
INCREASING THEIR CAPACITY TO
SHELTER HOMELESS POPULATION IN
INSTITUTING NEW PROTOCOL TO
ENSURE PUBLIC HEALTH FOR THAT
POPULATION. FOOD BANKS ARE
RAMPING UP THEIR EFFORTS
SIGNIFICANTLY WHILE STRUGGLING
TO ADAPT A SHARP DROP IN THE
NUMBER OF VOLUNTEERS. AND ARE
SERVING A GROWING NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH STUDENT
SECURITY. TO BE EFFECTIVE
PROVIDERS. THAT THEY ARE DURING
A DISASTER NONPROFIT MUST HAVE
ACCESS TO AVAILABLE DISASTER
RESOURCES INCLUDING TO
DONATIONS AND VOLUNTEERS AS
WELL AS A SPECIFIC RESOURCE FOR
SERVING VOLUNTEER POPULATION
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT HERE THAT
MORE THAN FOUR POINT MILLION
POINT HERE. HELLO HERE
OVERLOOKED RESOURCE IN GENERAL
AND ESPECIALLY IN TIMES OF
CRISIS AB TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN
MANDATE THAT CAL O. YES DEVELOP
MODEL GUIDELINES FOR
IDENTIFYING AND TRACKING
COMMUNITY RESOURCES WILL HELP
NONPROFIT. SERVE COMMUNITIES
DURING DISASTERS THE
REQUIREMENT TO INCLUDE BEST
PRACTICES TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WILL
HELP NOT PROFIT MEET THOSE
NEEDS AND THE MANDATE THAT WE
APPLY WHAT WE LEARN FROM RECENT
DISASTERS TO HELP. BUT TO PLAN
WELL FOR FUTURE ONE COULDN'T BE
MORE SALIENT. BY HELPING TO
ENSURE THAT NONPROFIT ANOTHER
SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE ACCESS
THE DISASTER RESPONSE RESOURCES
AB. TWENTY EIGHTEEN HELPS
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S WILL
GET THE RESOURCES THEY NEED.
TIMES OF CRISIS. LIKE TODAY FOR
THESE REASONS CAL NONPROFIT ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE FOR THE BILL
AND WE WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND ALSO- THE
COMEDIANS CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE HAVE ADDITIONAL- TEST
MILLIONS FOR THE WE HAVE ONE
MORE. WE HAVE CHRIS CHILDS
ONLINE. HERE HERE NOTHING I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND ASK FOR A
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
HEARING NONE DO WE HAVE ANY.
OTHER TESTIMONY SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. OKAY NO PUBLIC
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. SEE NO QUESTIONS OR
TAKE IT BACK TO MISS LONG FOR
HER CLOSING STATEMENT. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN ITEM. THANK YOU MISS
THE MOST WE HAVE A- MOTION A
SECOND SIR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN
MOTION TO PASS WITH THE MAN'S
TO APPROPRIATIONS GRAY AYE GRAY
AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW I
AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN BERMAN I
BONTA BONTA AYE BRO RO I COOLEY
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER
DAILY DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA IN
ORDER GARCIA AYE GIPSON. GIPSON
AYE JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY. LOW LOW AYE MATHIS
MATHIS I MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE
AYE QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK SILVA
AYE AYE ROBERT RIVAS. BLANCA
RUBIO LONGER RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS HI BILLS OUT SEVENTEEN
VOTES THANK YOU MISS LOW THAT
BILLS OUT. OKAY MEMBERS THIS
TIME ORGAN MOVED ITEM TWENTY
AND YOUR GENDER WE'RE GOING TO
ASK MR GIPSON 2% HIS BILL AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY NINE REGARDING
THE GAMBLING CONTROL ACT. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. I THANK
YOU ALLOW ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY
NINE A FIRST OF ALL LET ME
GOING RECORDS ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I WANT TO
BRING OUT TWO POINTS MEMBERS ON
THIS BILL ALLOW AFFORDABILITY
OF GAMBLING LICENSE SO
EMPLOYEES. HOLD SIMILAR
POSITIONS WITH OTHER GAMBLING
ENTERPRISES WITHOUT NEEDING A
MULTIPLE LICENSE POINT NUMBER
TWO WEEKS IN THE STATE GATLING
LICENSE FOR EMPLOYEES. I'M TWO
YEARS TO THREE YEARS. THIS BILL
A MEMBERS LET ME BE CLEAR OF
ALL CASINO EMPLOYEES FROM THE
JANITOR TO THEM TO THE MANAGER
MY GLASSES ARE FOGGING UP. I'M
TO THE MANAGER CAN CONSIDER TO
HAVE A NEEDING A LICENSE THE
CURRENT LICENSE PROCESS USUALLY
TAKES ACCESS SIX MONTHS DELAYS
DISADVANTAGE CASINO- EMPLOYEES
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ENSURE.
EMPLOYEES DO NOT LOSE THEIR
JOBS DUE TO THE DELAY IN THE
LICENSE PROCESS CURRENTLY. FOR
LICE THEY MAKE ONLY WORK OUT AT
THAT CASINO THEY WERE EMPLOYED
WITHIN THE RITUAL LICENSE WAS
GIVING A. B. THIRTY ONE- SIXTY
NINE SIX TO STREAMLINE THE
LICENSING PROCESS BY REMOVING
THE RESTRICTIONS AND BARRIERS
AND ULTIMATELY BENEFITING THOSE
EMPLOYEES WHO MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO RECEIVE FULL TIME AND-
IMPORTANT WORK AT OTHER
LOCATIONS. FURTHERMORE THIS
BILL SHIP FOR THE LICENSE FROM
A TWO YEAR RENEWAL TO A THREE
YEAR RENEWAL THIS YEAR'S.
INSURERS EMPLOYEES WON'T HAVE
CONSISTENTLY RENEW THEIR
LICENSE. OR GET TRAPPED BY A
BACKLOG OF LAW SINCE THE
PROCESS. A BY SENDING THE LOOK
OF THE LICENSE SB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY NINE WE'RE USE THE NUMBER
ANNUAL ROUTE. AND HOPEFULLY
PREVENT A FEW LAW. BLOG DOLLARS
WE ASK ROOMS TO TESTIFY BY TWO
ASSIST. THE WELL WHICH GIVES
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SOME
HERE TO YES I DO-
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE-
COMMUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA CAR
ROOMS TO BE ON THE LINE OR IN
THAT LITTLE ROOM SOMEWHERE OKAY
SIR THANK BRIAN LONG FROM KEW
CALVET CARTER JR BLINDING FROM
LUCKY CHANCES CONSIDER TO BE
JOINING US VIA VIDEO CONFERENCE
MEMBERS DIRECTOR TO THE FRONT
OF THE ROOM. CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. RIGHT ONE. ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITIES CALIFORNIA
CARD ROOMS TO THE SPONSOR WITH
THE LEGISLATION I THIS BILL IS
A NEEDED MEASURED RESPONSE
OBSTACLES IN SEEKING EMPLOYMENT
IN OUR INDUSTRY WHICH PROVIDES
OVER THIRTY THOUSAND LIVING
WAGE JOBS THAT PROVIDES
MILLIONS OF TAX AND FEE
REVENUES TO LOG ON STATE
GOVERNMENT THIS CURRENT TOO
RESTRICTIVE. SINCE THE
REGULATION HAD NO PROTECTION TO
SEEKING EMPLOYMENT SPECIAL
DURING THIS TIME OF HEALTH
RELATED CRISIS OF LIVELIHOOD
CHALLENGES THE CHANGE O LAW
WOULD ALLOW SINGLE PORTABLE
LICENSE FOR WORKERS TO GAIN
EMPLOYMENT MORE THAN ONE GAMING
CLUB. AS WELL AS ANY LIKE THE
LICENSE UPON APPROPRIATE
APPROVAL. IS EVER PRESENT
BACKLOG OF LICENSING. AND
EMPLOYEE PERSONS MORE QUICKLY
AND- ALL THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOUR- LONG IN ARE YOU
AVAILABLE VIA VIDEO CONFERENCE
AND THERE HE IS. MEMBERSHIP
WHAT AND I'LL BE HAVE A LUCKY
CHANCES CASINO WOULD SUPPORT
HERE TO OFFER ANY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL A
TESTAMENT TO THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE DO WE HAVE ANY TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION. SEEING HERE NOW
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THIS QUIRK SILVA YES- I WANTED
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY NINE I
THINK AS THIS REFERS TO
GAMBLING IT'S NOT ONLY
IMPORTANT BUT IN ALL OF OUR
SECTORS WERE REALLY GOING TO
HAVE TO AS- NOT ONLY A STATE
BUT AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY.
START TO LOOK AT ALL AREAS THAT
WE CAN WHETHER IT BE
STREAMLINED WHETHER IT BE. MAKE
IT EASIER FOR OFFICES FOR
NORMALLY PEOPLE TO KEEP THE
JOBS THEY HAVE. BUT MAKE SURE
THEY DON'T HAVE ARONIE US STEPS
TO. GO THROUGH IN THE NEXT
HANDFUL OF YEARS AS WE KNOW.
SOMETHING THAT SEEMS. NOT TOO
HARD TO DO BUT GETTING A
LICENSE THAT COULD TAKE QUITE A
LONG TIME IS A MAJOR THING TO
DO SO I SUPPORT THIS AND THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MS WORKS OF ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE WILL GO
AHEAD AND- BRING IT BACK TO
MISTER GIBSON FOR HIS CLOTHES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK THE
KIND OF MEMBER FROM ORANGE
COUNTY FOR HER KIND WORDS AND I
WILL MISS HER WORDS AS MY
CLOTHES. THANK YOU. OKAY OF
MOTIONS SECOND SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB THREE ONE SIX
NINE DO PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS
TO APPROPRIATIONS GRAY HI GREAT
HI BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN BERMAN I
BONTA BONTA AYE BRO ROLL AYE
COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER DALY
DALY AYE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
AYE GIPSON GIPSON I JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LOW LOW AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ HI QUIRK
SILVA. QUIRK SILVA AYE
ROBERT RIVAS LONGER RUBIO
LONGER RUBIO AYE SALAS. SALAS
HI THE BILL'S OUT WITH
SEVENTEEN VOTES. OKAY THAT
BILLS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON. MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
COMMITTEE BILLS ARE- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO HAVE BILLS RATHER.
AND. SEEING NOBODY WERE PRESENT
BY MYSELF I GUESS I WILL HAND
THE GAVEL TO WHO ARE THE VICE
CHAIRMAN MISTER BIGELOW AND I
WILL GO AHEAD AND PRESENT ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU. MISTER BIGELOW.
THE CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO THE
PRESENT UNTIL. YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND YOU HAVE A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THE TOPIC OF EQUINE
HUMAN SAFETY IN THE SPORT OF
HORSE REYES COMPLEX THAT TIMES
PERPLEXING. HOWEVER CALIFORNIA
IS ALWAYS BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
PROACTIVE RACING JURISDICTIONS
IN THE COUNTRY. REGULATORY
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS BY HAVE
IMPROVE THE MANY FACETS OF
INTEGRITY TRANSPARENCY WELFARE
AND SAFETY WHILE AFFORDING IT'S
REQUIRED IN HUMAN PARTICIPANTS
THE MOST PROTECTION POSSIBLE
WHETHER AMTRAK SAFETY.
MEDICATION STANDARDS DRUG
TESTING OR RESEARCH. THE LAST
SIXTEEN MONTHS HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY CHALLENGING FOR
CALIFORNIA'S HORSE RACING
INDUSTRY FROM THE USUAL
INCREASE IN FATALITIES THAT
OCCURRED IN THE EARLY TWENTY
NINETEEN TO THE RECENT ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP CAUSED BY THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC. BUT IN BOTH CASES THE
INDUSTRY FACES CHALLENGES HEAD
ON WITH DETERMINATION AND
RESOLVE. IN RESPONSE TO THE
RECENT SAFETY CRISIS
CALIFORNIA'S RACING INDUSTRY IN
THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD ADOPTED STRINGENT RULES
REGULATIONS AND PROTOCOLS. FOR
MEDICATION REFORM ADVANCE
VETERINARIAN SCREENING TRACK
MAINTENANCE INCLUDING SPECIAL
MEASURES DURING RAIN OR EXTREME
WEATHER CONDITIONS AND THE USE
OF HIGH TECH DIAGNOSTIC
EQUIPMENT INCLUDING PTN MRI
MACHINES. THESE WIDE RANGING
CHANGES AND PROTOCOLS OF LEAD
TO SAFER RACING AFTER THE SPIKE
IN FATAL BREAK DOWN TO SANTA
ANITA DURING THE TWENTY
NINETEEN RACE MAY. I MUST NOTE
THAT ALL THESE EFFORTS RESULTED
IN A REDUCTION. BUT NOT THE
TOTAL ELIMINATION OF COURSE
FIDELITY'S. IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT A RECENTLY RELEASED C. H.
R. B. REPORT FOUND NO ILLEGAL
MEDICATIONS AND ANY OF THE
HORSE TO US THAT OUR CURRENT
SANTA NEED A BETWEEN DECEMBER
THIRTIETH AND MARCH THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY NINETEEN. IN
ADDITION POST COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE FOUND NO
CRIMINAL WRONGDOING AT SANTA
ANITA PARK. THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY CAME FROM NUMEROUS
DISCUSSIONS RESEARCH I JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WITH THE
SENATE ON THIS TOPIC LAST
SPRING. DETAILED INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTS BY THE C. H. R. BE IN
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND THE
ONGOING EFFORT AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL TO ADVANCE REFORM. SENATE
CHAIRMAN BILL DODD NIGHT OR
BOTH OFFERING THESE BILLS THIS
YEAR TO BUILD ON LAST YEAR'S
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA IS THE SAFEST
RACING JURISDICTION IN THE
NATION. AND CONTINUES AS THE
GOLD STANDARD FOR OTHER STATES
TO FOLLOW. I BELIEVE THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
INDUSTRY LIKE MANY INDUSTRIES
MUST BE WILLING TO ACCEPT A DOT
FORWARD THINKING SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS LONGSTANDING ISSUES AND
DEBATES AS THE HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF THE SPORTS EQUINE
AND HUMAN ATHLETES ARE
PARAMOUNT TO. FUTURE OF THIS
AGRIBUSINESS. AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR WERE FURTHER
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S HORSE
RACING LAW WITH PROACTIVE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AIMED
AT ENSURING INCREASED OVERSIGHT
AND SAFETY AT ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S RACETRACKS.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR VOTE TODAY BY
TELECONFERENCE IN SUPPORT WE
HAVE BOTH TOM ROBBINS DIRECTOR
BRACING FOR DEL MAR
THOROUGHBRED CLUB. AND LOUIS
BREAD CALIFORNIA AUTHORITY OF
RACING FAIRS. WITH THE SPEAKERS
LIKE TO OR THE PEOPLE ON-
CONFERENCE CALL WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE. HELLO
HELLO HI THIS IS TOM ROBBINS.
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU
PROCEED. OKAY FIRST A QUICK
INTRODUCTION ABOUT MYSELF I'VE
BEEN. WORKING AND HAVING
RAISING DEPARTMENTS AND IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
LAST FORTY YEARS GLUTEN SANTA
ANITA HOLLYWOOD PARK IN DEL MAR
IN CURRENTLY SERVICE THE
DIRECTOR OF RACING VICE
PRESIDENT RACING OF DEL MAR
THOROUGHBRED CLUB. AND I WANT
TO SAY FIRST WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE CHAIRMAN GRAY'S
LEADERSHIP ON THIS LEGISLATION
THAT ENHANCES THE SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIA- THEIR BRAINS
RATIONS HUMAN ANNE KLEIN
ATHLETES AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE LEGISLATURE. AS
THE CHAIRMAN NOTED THE PAST
FOURTEEN MONTHS. THE CALIFORNIA
RACING INDUSTRY IS IMPLEMENTED-
SEVERAL VERY IMPORTANT
PROTOCOLS AND PROCEDURES
RELATED TO MEDICATION
RESTRICTIONS. OF VETERINARY
OVERSIGHT AND AN OVERALL SAFETY
OF OUR HORSES- I WANNA PROUDLY
PER SE DEL MAR- EXPERIENCE SOME
ISSUES IN TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING BOARD. AND IT'S EVEN
MEDICAL RECTOR DOCTOR READ
THERE ARE AN ESTABLISHED
PROTOCOLS. GOING IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN DEL MAR SUMMER MADE
IF IT ENDED UP BEING ONE OF THE
SAFEST WE'VE EVER HAD REGARDED-
ONE OF THE SAFEST IN THE
COUNTRY AND FURTHER MORE IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN WE WERE REGARDED AS
THE SAFEST. RACE MADE AND ALL
OF HEM GOT THE PROOF IS
CERTAINLY IN THE PUTTING SOME
OF THESE MEASURES THAT DEL MAR
AND OTHER RACETRACKS IN
CALIFORNIA DIMPLE MEN. ARE THIS
ENTRY REVIEW PANEL WHICH IS.
AGAIN HEADED BY OUR REQUIRE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR DR ARTHUR.
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF THE HORSES
ARE BEING ENTERED ON A DAILY
BASIS THE CALIFORNIA RACE
TRACKS IT ALSO NEEDS TO BE
NOTED THAT THE WE ARE NOT JUST
AN ISLAND IN CALIFORNIA THESE-
MEASURES ARE BEING ADOPTED BY
OTHER RACETRACKS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY JUST NOT IN CALIFORNIA
SO IT'S PRETTY DARN SIGNIFICANT
WHAT WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED.
MEDICATION REFORM- THERAPEUTIC
MEDICATIONS SOMETIMES CAN- TO
PROVIDE OUR HORSE LOOKING BY A
REGULATORY VETERINARIAN OR
LOOKED AT BY REGULATORY THERE
AND MAYBE NOT IN ITS NATURAL
STATE SO SOME OF THESE REFORMS
INCLUDE- CREATING LONGER STAND
DOWN PERIODS NON NONSTEROIDAL
ANTI INFORMED INFLAMMATORY
DRUGS- WE'VE ALSO ADDITIONAL
VETERINARY OBSERVATION AGAIN
THIS HAPPENED EARLY AT DEL MAR
BUT IT'S BEEN AND- VERY
IMPORTANT. PLACE AT THE END IN
ALL UP SOUTHERN CAL. AND
CALIFORNIA'S WEALTH THE I IT IS
QUITE A AND TO THE FUTURE OF
OUR OUR- ASHLEY I WANT TO
MENTION TO THE OP. THAT BRING
PARTY MEDICARE TEN AND RESEARCH.
YEAH CAT VERY LUCKY TO HAVE THE
CAN YOU QUAN ANALYTICAL. LAB
THAT DAVIS. NOT JUST ONE OF THE
RECORD AS ONE OF THE BEST IN
THE IT'S WRECK TO BE ONE OF THE
BEST IN THE WORLD AND IT'S- IN
OVER TEN TO THE AND LAST SAMPLE
WERE ANALYZED THROUGH THE LAB.
LAST YEAR COST OF OVER THREE
MILLION. THEY CONTINUE TO- ADD
ADDITIONAL MEDICATIONS TO THOSE
TESTS- AS THOSE ARE PEOPLE ON
MEDICAL DIRECTORS SEVEN IT IS A
BIT OF A CAT AND MOUSE GAME AND
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE ENSURE
THAT ALL OF OUR PLAYERS ON A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD. I BEEN
COLLUDED WITH THAT. COMMENT AND
HAVE BEEN ANSWER ANY. SINGLE
QUESTIONS THERE A CELL PERSON
WE TO IT IN SUPPORT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN A LOUIS BROWN BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA FORTY OF RAISING
FAIR I WHOLEHEARTEDLY ENDORSE
EVERYTHING MISS ROBIN THAT. I
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE CHAIRMAN
AND CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE GEO
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP
IN THIS AREA CALIFORNIA REGION
FAIRS HAVE A STRONG HISTORY OF
SAFETY- AND WE MADE IT A
PRIORITY TO LOOK OUT FOR- THE
REPORT IS AS WELL AS OUR DECENT
SO. APPRECIATE LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OF A
SCENE QUESTIONS FROM ANYONE IS
THERE ANY OTHER ONE IN SUPPORT.
HEARING NONE SEEING YES I DO
SEE ONE IN THE AUDIENCE APPEAR
IN THE TOP. THANK YOU SCOTT I'M
SORRY MR WHICH. WELL HOLD ON
OUR SPEAKER CAN YOU GET HIS
MIKE TO WORK. PUSH THE BUTTON
AT THE BOTTOM. TO HAVE A
SERGEANT I CAN MAYBE HELP THEM.
ON THE BOTTOM OF THE MIKE I
THINK IT'S A WIRELESS MIKE YOU.
LOOK RIGHT THERE MISTER WHICH-
LITTLE TINY BUTTON. RED. AREA
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHICH
ON BEHALF OF THE STRONGER GROUP
THE LOS ANGELES TURF CLUB IN
THE PACIFIC RACING ASSOCIATION
LIKE TO THANK THE ENTIRE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF IN- THE
CHAIRMAN AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU. A
LOT OF EFFORT THANK YOU MISTER
WHICH- ANY OPPOSITION. ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE FARM. HEARING
AND SEEING NINE BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR. WITH THE SIGNAL
IN RALEIGH TO THE CALL WITH THE
AUTHOR LIKE CLOTHES. THANK YOU
MEMBERS- CALIFORNIA HAS LONG.
BEEN THE GOLD STANDARD RAISING
THIS COUNTRY- WE HAVE A STORIED
TRADITION AND WE HAVE ALWAYS
LED THE WAY IN THE MOST
INNOVATIVE- PRACTICES- AND
SAFETY MEASURES SO THIS. BILL
CONTINUES THAT TRADITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. COULD WE CALL THE
ROLL. AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
GRAY THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BREAK HI
GREAT HI BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. BERMAN BERMAN
I BONTA BONTA AYE BRO BRO I
COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER DALY.
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I EDUARDO
GARCIA AND WROTE A GARCIA AYE
GIPSON GIPSON I'D JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LOW
LOW AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK
SILVA. QUIRK SILVA AYE ROBERT
RIVAS. BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA
RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS HI THE
BILL'S OUT WITH SIXTEEN VOTES.
AS CHAIR HAT BILL IS
SUCCESSFUL CONGRATULATIONS NOW
PLEASE RESUME THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIR. MEMBERS AT THIS
JUNCTURE WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY WHO'S BEEN UP
STAIRS CHAIRING HER COMMITTEE
FOR THE PAST FEW MINUTES TO
PRESENT HER BILL AB. TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT FOR RELATIVE TO
OUR STATE AGENCIES THIS IS ITEM
THREE ON YOUR GENDER IS MEMBERS
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU HAVE A
MOTIONS. WELL I DO THIS QUICKLY
INDUSTRY WITH THE NINE THIS
AMERICAN PUBLIC ME ALMOST OVER.
AND REMOVE FROM A PURSE A PER
TO ONLINE INTO FOR. SO WE NEED
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES TO CLOSE LOOPHOLES IN
THE BIG LEAGUES. CAME OPEN
MEETING ACT WITH THAT I ASKED
RIVALS. THANK YOU DO HAVE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE OR VIA VIDEO
CONFERENCE- AT THIS TIME SEEING
NONE HERE THE CHAMBER. HEARING
NONE IN SEEING DOWN ON OUR
VIDEO CONFERENCE MEMBERS LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERSHIP
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SEEING
NUMBER THREE BACK TO THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR HER CLOTHES.
I SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM THANK
YOU. SECRETARY TO. HOLD ON WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF LATE WITNESSES
SO BEAR WITH US ON OUR
COMMUNICATION HERE PLEASE-
PRESENT YOUR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. ALRIGHT
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE THIRTY
SIX PEOPLE AT. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES WE CAN. STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATIONAL. SO WHAT SOCIAL
COMPASSIONATE LEGISLATION AND
THERE WERE THREE OF US ON HOLD
FOR THE FOR RACE SCENE THEY'LL
AND WE CALL IN OPPOSITION. AND
WE ALL GOT NUMBERS OF TWO OTHER
PEOPLE WERE NUMBER ONE OH EIGHT
AND I WAS ONE THIRTY DAY AND WE
GOT COMPLETELY IGNORED AND YET
AND YOU WENT TO THE BOTTLE AND
WE NEVER EVEN GOT BEAT SO
HELPFUL EVEN THOUGH THAT I
TRIED TO GET IN HERE. TO SAY
THE THIS OBVIOUSLY NOT BECAUSE
NOT WATER THE YOU'RE STILL AND
I'M NOT CALLING FOR HIS BILLION
BUILD BUT WE'RE VERY UPSET THAT
WE DID NOT GET TO GET OUR- ON
OUT IN IT AND YOU'RE GOING WELL.
SOME SO IF YOU LIKE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY AD MEMBERS TO
CLARIFY THE TEST WAS BEING
PROVIDED ON MY BILL AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR SO PLEASE PRESENT
YOUR TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
TO. SEVENTY AND THAT TURN TO
THE DEBATE ON THE CURB EVERY.
OKAY GOT OKAY SO- I NAPA NICK
SACKETT WHO WAS ONE NO WAIT AS
THE TESTIMONY READY TO GO AHEAD
AND- YES WE ARE PUBLIC I FELT
LIKE IT WE APOLOGIZE.
AMENDMENTS ALL THESE OF THE
ALTAR. WE HAVE YOUR THE TAP
CALLED HER FOR IN THE STATE WHY
BUT OF COURSE LIKE YOURSELF
THAT NOT NEARLY HEART SHE BACK
FOR ANIMAL WELFARE AND AS WELL
GAGE RP HAD JOBS FOR NUMBER
MEASURES PROTECT FOR EACH. ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL INCLUDING
ISSUES REALLY TO. ON TRAINING
YES EDUCATION OUR RECORDS
ACTUAL WORKING OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN IS THAT YOU CAN THANK
YOU ORDER NOT YOUR TYPICAL
PROLIFERATION DRUG ON THE TRACK
OF PHARMACY. WE LOOK FORWARD.
AND WORK WITH THE OTHER STATE
CALL THE BILL HAS CHANGE HORSE
JOCKEY. THREE WEEKS AGO AND IT-WAS PRETTY CLEAR THAT YOU PRESS
LIKE NUMBER TWO TO RAISE YOUR
HAND AND YOU'RE PUT IN HERE. AT
AND BUT ARE THERE ANY OKAY
KATHY YERMO WITHOUT PEOPLE FOR
THE ETHICAL TREATMENT OF. GO
AHEAD YEAH THE- YEAH I THINK
THERE ARE ISSUES WHAT SPELL
ALTHOUGH DOESN'T COUNT DEAL
SOME OF THE- ISSUES THEN RUN
THANKS. BLOCK BILL NOT. PLEASE
WELL I SURE BILL AND ALL TO
FALL BUT BOB THIS STANDARD BUT
THE REPORT OF. YOUR TRACK WITH
BURGER SECOND QUESTION FROM THE
LIST OF MEDICATIONS. THE PAIN
MEDICATION ONLY FROM THE
PHARMACY RATHER THAN BRINGING
ACOSTA TRAPPING SO. I'LL COME
RAISING MUCH OF A FRACTION OF
THE INJURY. HELLO. CLICK TO
FIND IN THIS BILL. MRR AFGHANS
CAN BECAUSE THE SCREENING
DEVICES FOR LARGE NUMBERS OF
COURSE THAT I SEE KIDS CAN'T
CAN'T. BUT WE WERE. IT CAN'T
BUT LOWER NOW OF RADIATION IS
FOR SPRING CAUTIOUS SO MANY
INJURIES ARE NOT SURE. RATHER
THAN SIMPLY LIKE. ACOSTA
ALREADY SHOWN FOR LINDA.
DESPITE CLEAR AFTER. SHARKS
CALLED IN ORDER OUT THERE'S NO
MEASURE ON. OKAY MY PHONE JUST
DROPPED DID YOU HEAR THAT
TESTIMONY FROM NECK AND AT THE.
HELLO. CAN YOU HEAR US OKAY YES
WE CAN- DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY- AGAIN
WE'VE MADE A SPECIAL ORDER HERE
TO TAKE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
AND ITEM TO AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
FORCE OR ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR GRAY.
OKAY WHAT THANK YOU FOR PUTTING
THAT IN THE RECORD AND
OBVIOUSLY THIS NEEDS A LOT OF
WAR AND IF THEY COULD WORK LIKE
THAT FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
COULD YOU. IDENTIFY YOURSELF-
YOU JUMPED IN THEIR- FOR THE
MEASURE DIDN'T YOU DEMAND
DOLLARS. YOU DEMAND CRUCIAL
SOCIAL COMPASSION LEGISLATION.
THERE WAS NO INSTRUCTIONS AND
WE WERE NOT CALLED UPON FOR THE
RECORD THANK YOU. OKAY SO
MEMBERS- HERE'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN TO THE BILL CURRENTLY
BEFORE US WHICH IS THE
AGUIAR-CURRY BILL. AND WE'LL
TAKE A VOTE ON THAT AFTER WHICH.
WE'RE GOING TO RETURN TO ITEM.
ALL THE. SO MEMBERS ARE WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND VOTE ON THE
ITEM OF FORCE WHICH IS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGO THEN I'M GOING
TO ASK THE COMMITTEE- BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RESCIND
THE VOTE ON MY ITEM GIVEN THAT
WE HAD ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT
MEMBERS HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR THAT TESTIMONY AND CAST
THEIR VOTE AGAIN- SO AGAIN
WE'RE GOING TO START BY FISHING
INCLUDING OUR BUSINESS ON THE
AGUIAR-CURRY BUILD THIS IS ITEM
THREE AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT.
WE HAVE CONCLUDED OUR TESTIMONY
ON THAT- THE AUTHOR HAS DONE
HER CLOTHES- WE ARE NOW ALL WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND. AND SO
WE'RE GOING TO. ASK THE
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL
AGAIN ON ITEM THREE AB TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT AGUIAR-CURRY.
SECTOR AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS GRAY. I GRAY AYE
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BERMAN BERMAN I BONTA BONTA AYE
BRO. BRO I COOLEY. COOPER DALY
DALY I GALLAGHER. EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA AYE
GIPSON. GIPSON I JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
AYE LOW LOW I MATHIS. MATHIS I
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK
SILVA. ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I BLANCA RUBIO
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS HI
THE BILL HAS SEVENTEEN VOTES IN
IS OUT. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY SO
AGAIN MEMBERS I AM NOW GOING TO
ASK THE COMMITTEE- BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT IF THAT'S OKAY WITH
EVERYONE TO RESCIND THE VOTE ON
ITEM NUMBER TWO. MY BILL AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR DO WE
HAVE ANY OBJECTION. SEEING NONE.
WE WILL NOW TAKE THE VOTE AGAIN
WE HAVE A MOTION. ITEM TWO A.
B. NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR GRAY.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND. WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND. AB
NINETEEN SEVETY FOUR GRAY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS GRAY. HI GREAT
HI BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BERMAN BERMAN I'D BONTA BONTA I
BROKE. WROTE I COOLEY COOLEY
AYE COOPER DALY DALY AYE
GALLAGHER. EDUARDO GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GIPSON
GIPSON I'D JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
LOW LOW I MATHIS MATHIS HI
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ HI QUIRK
SILVA. ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS HI BLANCA RUBIO
LONGER RUBIO AYE SALAS. SALAS I
GALLAGHER HI THE BILL IS OUT
WITH EIGHTEEN VOTES. OKAY
MEMBERS THAT BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH ME ON THAT
I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE GIVEN
THE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY- THAT
WE MAKE SURE WE HAVE CONDUCTED
OUR PROCESS- FAIRLY AND WITH
ALL PUBLIC INPUT. REMINDER TO
THE PUBLIC AND ANY WITNESSES WE
HAVE GOING FORWARD WHEN YOU
REFER TO A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE YOU SHOULD USE THE
OFFICIAL. REFERENCE OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- ASSEMBLY MEDICINE THE
WOMAN ETCETERA- ONE OF THE
WITNESSES I THINK REFERRED TO A
MEMBER BY HER FIRST NAME. I
WOULD LIKE TO MAINTAIN OUR
PROTOCOL- HEARING COMMITTEE SO
MEMBERS AT THIS. JUNCTURE WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO OUR FINAL ITEM ON
TODAY'S AGENDA AND THAT'S AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY SEVEN- BY
SELLING MEMBER RIVAS AND WE
WOULD ASK THIS ELEMENT TO
APPROACH A PRESENT. I HIS BILL
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR COLLEAGUES TO KEEP THIS
BRIEF. PLEASED TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO NINE FIVE
SEVEN A BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW
LICENSE WINERIES TO FILL. THESE
CONSUMER PROVIDER BOTTLES
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS GROWLERS-
THIS COVERT NINETY PANDEMIC IS
GRAY NEW CHALLENGES FOR OUR
STATE NEW CHALLENGES FOR
CONSTITUENCIES BACK HOME. AND
AS THREATEN MANY MANY
INDUSTRIES IN OUR STATE ONE
SUCH INDUSTRY I'M PROUD TO
REPRESENT- THAT HAS IT HOW TO
GROWING FOOTPRINT NOT ONLY BACK
HOME IN MY DISTRICT BUT
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE IS THE
WIND DISTRAUGHT. NOW DO TO OUR
HEALTH CRISIS IS ESTIMATED THAT
CALIFORNIA'S WINERIES WILL
SUFFER IN 80% 80% OR TWO POINT
FIVE FOUR- A BILLION DOLLAR
LOSS. IN ONSITE SALES AMONG
OTHER NET LOSSES. AS A FORMER
RELEASED THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
CONTROL DIRECTOR IS ALLOWING
WINERIES TO REFILL- THESE
CONSUMER PROVIDED BOTTLES-
RIGHT NOW AS WE FACE HEALTH
CRISIS. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
CODIFY THIS REAL THIS THIS FORM
OF RELIEF. WITH ME- HERE
TODAY'S CAN STEMPLER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE MONTEREY COUNTY
VENTURES AND MONO COUNTY- THE
BETTER THE GROWERS ASSOCIATION
AND MICHAEL MILLER WITH THE
COMPOSITION OF WINE GRAPE
GROWERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU IS NUMBER RIVAS- DO
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL. TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT. OF THIS
BILL. ANYBODY ON THE TELEPHONE
OR VIDEO CONFERENCE YOU SEE
NOBODY THE CHAMBER AT THIS TIME.
HELLO OKAY HERE YOU GO AHEAD
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION. I THANK YOU THE
DIRECTOR OF THE HIRING. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS I THANK YOU THE
NUMBER. WE APPRECIATE ALL THAT
YOU'RE DOING I HAD HELP KEEP US
SAFE DURING UNPRECEDENTED TIME.
WAS BORN FROM A QUESTION ONE OF
OUR BUT KEEP WINERIES AT THE A.
B. C. DIRECTOR THEIR ANNUAL
MEETING LAST YEAR EVEN OUR
DESIRE TO BE INCREASINGLY
SUSTAINABLE THEY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY A BREWERY COULD
RE FEEL CONSUMERS BOTTLE
RATTLERS. AND THEIR WINERY
STATEMENTS COULD NOT THE
DIRECTOR TO PORTED AND HELP
SUPPORTIVE AND HOPE THAT
INVESTIGATING DEVELOP A PLAN TO
BRING US TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY
WITH THE SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REPAST. THE LIMITATION
WAS BECAUSE OF ONE SENTENCE IN
THE BUSINESS CODES CREEK
PROHIBITING CONSUMER SUPPLIED
BOTTLES ALTHOUGH THIS EFFORT IS
IMPORTANT FROM ASSISTING
ABILITY PERSPECTIVE STAVING
THIRTY NINE BOTTLES WITH ONE
SINGLE WHITE. IT BECOMES EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT GIVEN THE COVER
CRISIS IN MONTEREY COUNTY ALONE
OR SEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN LAID OFF FROM MY SIXTY
FIVE GRAMS. SMALL WIRY THE
FACING CLOSURES OF THEIR
CLOTHES FOR ON PREMISE CASINGS
AND WE NEED LONG TERM ECONOMIC
TO AFFECT THE REPUBLIC AND THIS
IS A SIMPLE ONE. FURTHER IS THE
GROWTH IN MYSELF. THROUGHOUT HI
HAS DECREASED. AND THE LAST FEW
YEARS OF. YIELDS HAVE BEEN A BY.
OUR IN OUR OUR IN A VULNERABLE
POSITION AS WELL. ALTHOUGH THE
ACTUAL. IS ON. WE KNOW IN
MODERN COUNTY LET YEAR LONG
SHOVEL. BY FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
ACRES CULTIVATED BREAKS COULD
NOT GET HARPER BECAUSE OF LACK
OF DEMAND. YEAH BUT YOU STILL
CONSUMER FIGHT. OPTIONAL FOR
WINERIES ONLY APPLIES TO
LICENSE WINERIES. FURTHER ANY
NECESSARY SAFETY MEASURES WILL
BE. RELATED TO COVERAGE WILL BE
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT. AS AN
INDUSTRY. WE ARE THE OPERATE
UNDER STRICT. BYE BYE. ON TOP
OF THAT LOCALLY HAD ABOUT OUR
OWN. PROTOCOL TO UP. STATEMENTS
THAT ARE INFORM BY THE WINE
INSTITUTE. STATEWIDE PROTOCOLS.
ENCLOSURE THIS BILL OFFERS
WINERIES AN ADDITIONAL TOOL TO
HELP THEM RECOVER FROM COVERAGE
THIS TOOL WILL CREATE A
EDUCTION USES THE FLAT THE
USAGE OF FLASH THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND BRING GREATER
ATTENTION. THE IMPORTANCE OF
REUSING AND RECYCLING. IT ALSO
HELPS WINERIES DEEPER
CONNECTIONS WITH THE
COMMUNITIES AND BRINGS THE WINE
INDUSTRY INTO PARITY WITH. YOUR
PARTNERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND I'M. AVAILABLE
TO RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS. THIS IS MICHAEL MILLER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF WINE GRAPE GROWERS AND I
GUESS WHAT I'M INITIALLY
DESPITE BEING AUTHORED THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
COMMITTEE STAFF AND WHAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENED MEMBERS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE ISLAND IN BOTH
HOUSES YOU GUYS DOING
EXTRAORDINARY WORK THE MOST
DIFFICULT TIMES AND I CANNOT
IMAGINE PUBLIC SERVICE THE MORE
DIFFICULT IN THIS SITUATION AND
I PERSONALLY AND PROFESSIONALLY
ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
ON THAT SET I DO WANNA LET
MYSELF OFF THE MOST COMMENTS-
CAPRI ASSOCIATION MIKE OF
COURSE WAS THE FORCES BELL B.
GROWERS WERE SELLING TO
WINERIES WHO ARE RELYING DIRECT
SALES WILL BE ESPECIALLY HARD
HIT WITH A COVER NINETY NINE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND THEY
WON'T NEED ANY REALLY POSSIBLE
COMING OUT OF THIS IS THAT THE
WE CAN ALLOW FOR YA INNOVATIVE
SALES AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
WILL BE WILL HELP THE INDUSTRY
RECOVER. POST PAID BACK AND WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
YEAH COMMITTEE. AND I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE ABOUT. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE A POWER LINE OF
ONE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS OUR- THE PROGRAM
HOME FROM THE BOARD BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES. MAKE A COMMENT ON AB
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT- I SKIPPED
OVER FOR THAT AND WE HAVE BEEN
OPPOSE ABOUT AMENDED POSITION
ON THAT BILL I'M NOT SUPPORT
WHAT IF YOU GIVE YOUR FINANCES
WE RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
FOR PUBLIC DISCLOSURE AND
TRANSPARENCY AND WE ALWAYS.
STRIVE TO ACHIEVE IT. OUR BOARD
HAS SERIOUS CONCERNS THAT IT
WILL DISRUPT ABILITY TO TAKE
CONDITION BY LEGISLATION THE
FUTURE. OF LEGISLATION IS OFTEN
AMENDED DURING THE TEN DAYS THE
AGENDA POST AND THE TIMES THE
PARKING CONSIDERATE- AND
THEREFORE WE- WHAT WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO RECONSIDER CENTER ANY
AMEND SELF WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THIS CONCERN BE
CONSIDERED. THANK. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY AT
THIS TIME. THE LITTLE ONE. OKAY
THIS TIME. LAST CALL. OKAY
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE EMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS REGARDING MR REDUCES
BILL. SEEING NONE- LET'S TAKE
IT BACK TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS FOR HIS CLOSE RESPECT
LAST WHEN I LOOK. THANK YOU-
MISSED RIVAS WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND- SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB TWO NINE FIVE
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS RAY. I RATE HI
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I
BERMAN BERMAN I BONTA BONTA I
BROKE BRO HI COOLY COOLEY AYE
COOPER DAILY DALY AYE GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GIPSON
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
LOW LOW AYE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE AYE QUIRK
SILVA. ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I BLANCA RUBIO
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I
THE BILL IS OUT WITH NINETEEN
VOTES. THAT BILLS OUT MEMBERS
THAT CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS
HERE TODAY WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN-
ON THE ROOM- ON THE AGENDA FOR
THE NEXT FIVE MINUTES FOR
MEMBERS TO. ADD ON.
CONSENT
CALENDAR HI ROBERT RIVAS. AB
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE SALAS SALAS
HI ROBERT RIVAS. AB NINETEEN
SEVEN YOUR THANK YOU FOR GRAY
ON HORSE RACING. OKAY RIVAS I.
YOUR GOOD THERE. AB TWO OH FIVE
FOUR COM WALKER DOVE ROBERT
RIVAS I. AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT ROBERT ROBERT RIVAS ON
LEVINE. ROBERT RIVAS I. AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN LOW MOAN
WITH AMENDMENTS ROBERT RIVAS I.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE
BIGELOW WITH AMENDMENTS ROBERT
RIVAS I. AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
NINE GIPSON WITH AMENDMENTS
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I.
HOME ALL GO DOWN OKAY OKAY YEAH
YEAH WE'LL DO THAT. CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS I KNOW RIGHT.
OKAY WE ARE HERE'S THE CONSENT
CALENDAR GOING TO CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I COOPER EDUARDO
GARCIA. AND WATER GARCIA HI
LACKEY LACKEY I. DAILY THERE
YOU GO. NEXT BILL AB NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE SALAS CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I COOPER. GIPSON
GIPSON I LACKEY LACKEY HI. AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR GRAY
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY HI
COOPER DALY. LACKEY LACKEY I.
AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
AGUIAR-CURRY ABSENT MEMBERS
COOPER GAG GALLAGHER GALLAGHER
HI QUIRK SILVA. AB TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR CALM WATER DOVE ABSENT
MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY HI COOPER
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER HI LACKEY
LACKEY HI. AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT LEVINE ABSENT
MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I COOPER. GIPSON
GIPSON HI LACKEY LACKEY I. AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN LOW MOAN
WITH AMENDMENTS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I COOPER. LACKEY
LACKEY BY. AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
NINE BIGELOW WITH AMENDMENTS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
COOPER. LACKEY LACKEY I. ITEM
FIFTEEN AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
SEVEN ROBERT RIVAS CALLING
ABSENT MEMBERS COOPER. QUIRK
SILVA. THAT'S IT WILL COME ON
THE. WE.